Let's get started.
Welcome.
We're with the master and the disciple, Jafar ibn Mansour al-Yaman 's dialogue and the lofty edge of part 2, where the disciple asks at last about air, the unpaired element that mixes with everything and is encompassed by nothing.
Air is the loftiest similitude, the sign that announces the failure of signs.
And if you have been following the threads of this text with us, we are setting out on a very specific, deliberate mission here.
We really are.
We have been mapping out this grand, just meticulously constructed architecture of creation.
The scholar in this dialogue has been guiding his student through this massive system
built entirely on a catalog of worldly symbols.
Yeah, it's a framework where physical, tangible things in our cosmos point directly to spiritual entities.
It is a brilliantly ordered system.
Completely peer-to-peer.
Exactly.
Everything in the lower physical cosmos has been neatly paired off to represent a specific rank of intermediary in the higher spiritual world.
It provides this sense of total intellectual mastery for the disciple.
You look at the earth and the scholar explains that the earth points downward to one specific rank.
Then you look at the islands and they point to another rank.
The flowing rivers point to yet another.
The disciple has been meticulously writing down this map.
Everything has a place, you know.
Everything has a counterpart.
But as perfect as this architecture seems, there is a glaring omission.
One element has been conspicuously absent from this peer-to-peer pointing.
It's just been sitting there quietly since the very first concept of this teaching, waiting to be addressed.
And the disciple is sharp.
He has been closely following the master's map.
and he finally spots the missing element.
He looks at the system and sees that every other element in the cosmos has a pair.
Heaven has the earth, the sun has the moon, salty water has sweet water.
And because they have peers, they can point downward to a rank of intermediaries.
But air, the very first of the seven elements, is completely alone.
It is unpaired.
It just encompasses everything else.
It mixes with everything, but nothing encompasses it.
So naturally the disciple asks about it.
He has his notebook out, so to speak, and he wants to know exactly what air symbolizes in the catalog.
He wants to finish the map.
And that is our mission.
We are going to explore this final element, air, and understand exactly how it brings this entire system of symbols
to its absolute limit.
But the scholar's response to the disciples' question is, well, it's a flat refusal.
He refuses to make air a symbol for any creation whatsoever.
He just shuts it down.
Completely.
He tells the student that air is simply too exalted to point downward to any spiritual rank because absolutely nothing in creation matches it.
I don't buy that yet.
No.
I mean, why can't air just be slotted into the catalog of created symbols like the rest of them?
If the heavens point to a rank and the earth points
to a rank.
Why can't air just point to the highest created rank?
You're asking why break the system at the very top?
Exactly.
Why break the pattern?
To answer that, the teacher doesn't just say no.
He knows the disciple needs to understand the mechanics of why it cannot be slotted in.
So he explains the scale.
He does.
He presents a scale of magnitudes.
He uses 3 nested comparisons to prove the absolute incomparability of air.
He tells the disciple, earth set against air is like a seal ring on a great plane.
Let's hold on to that and actually visualize it.
Think about a seal ring, just a tiny circular band of metal you would wear on your finger.
Yeah.
If you drop that ring onto a great plain, a flat, endless expanse of land stretching out infinitely in every direction to the horizon, that single tiny ring is the entire earth.
All of our mountains, all of our oceans, just that speck of metal.
Yes, and the plane itself represents air.
It is not just big, it is a terrifying scale.
It dwarfs the earth so completely that the earth practically ceases to exist in comparison.
But he doesn't stop there.
He doesn't.
He moves to the second magnitude.
He says, atmosphere set against the heavens is like a seal ring in a vast desert.
So the scale expands again.
We take the atmosphere, the very thing that just acted as the infinite plane surrounding the earth, and now we compare it to the heavens above.
And suddenly the atmosphere itself is reduced to another tiny ring.
Completely lost in an even larger, unimagined
desert.
The mind is forced to keep zooming out further and further.
Finally, he delivers the third magnitude.
The scholar says, heaven set against the full extent of air is like an egg on an immense plain.
Oh man.
The scale is staggering.
You stack these magnitudes together.
Earth is completely dwarfed by the atmosphere.
The atmosphere is completely dwarfed by the heavens.
And the heavens themselves, the ultimate ceiling of our reality, are reduced to the size of a fragile little egg sitting on an immense plane when compared to the full extent of air.
Air contains absolutely all of them.
Because of this absolute nested scale, the scholar explains that air cannot possibly point downward.
It cannot be slotted into a peer-to-peer system because it has no peer.
It can only point up one to the one who has no likeness, neither in the outward aspects nor the baton.
And since it encompasses everything else, there is no horizontal counterpart.
This inner dimension is completely singular.
It is.
But this revelation introduces a massive existential tension for the disciple.
He is a rigorous student and he knows his scripture.
He really does.
And he brings up an entirely reasonable objection based on the text.
He cites chapter 16, verse 74.
Or says.
So do not strike likenesses for Allah, for he knows and you do not.
It is a strict, undeniable prohibition against making comparisons.
That sounds like wordplay to me.
Peter just spent all this time using air as a sign.
It does seem like a contradiction at first glance.
I mean, he just walked through three massive comparisons about seal rings and planes to make us understand air.
and that he claims he isn't violating a clear verse that strictly forbids striking likenesses.
Yeah, it's a heavy accusation from the student.
If you use a physical element to point to the Creator, aren't you by definition making a likeness?
Well, the scholar untangles this apparent contradiction by going back to the exact same chapter of the Quran.
He quotes chapter 16, verse 60.
Okay, let's hear it.
And Allah's is the loftiest similitude.
So the disciple is looking at one verse, strictly forbidding likenesses,
And the scholar counters with another voice from the same chapter, affirming A loftiest similitude.
Exactly.
How do those two exist at the same time?
The master's doctrine lies in a very careful, profound distinction between two totally different kinds of signs.
Okay, break that down for us.
First, you have lesser signs.
These are forbidden as comparisons for the Creator.
Why?
Because if you use a lesser sign, you slot him into a pure relation alongside his creatures.
Meaning, if I say a flowing river points to a worldly guide, and then I say air points to the Creator, I have just made the Creator another item in a list of created things.
You've put the absolute ultimate reality on the same scale as a river or an island.
I have taken the most exalted and demoted him to just another rung on a ladder.
Precisely.
To use a lesser
is to diminish the absolute.
But the loftiest similitude is licensed because it functions entirely differently.
How so?
It stands at the absolute top of the ladder.
It is completely incomparable to its own peers.
It cannot slot the creator into a pure relation because air itself has no equal in the physical cosmos.
I see.
The comparison demonstrates incomparability through scale.
It does.
It is crucial to understand that the scholar is not saying that air is like the creator.
He is saying that nothing in creation is like air.
And therefore, nothing, including air itself, can be like the one who created it.
This entire framework is grounded in the apophatic anchor of classical theology.
Understanding through negation, stripping away our human concepts.
Yes.
When we try to describe the absolute highest
reality, any positive word we use, like powerful or vast, is still a human word.
It secretly smuggles human limits into the description.
Exactly.
So instead of asserting what the creator is, you rigorously define what he is not.
He's not measurable.
He is not bounded.
He is not a peer to anything we can observe.
This is specifically rooted in the chapter on consultation, verse 11.
It establishes definitively that no created predicate transfers cleanly to the creator.
This tension of knowing and not knowing.
is central to the entire journey.
We see it perfectly captured in that famous sacred saying.
The one translated by William Chittick.
Yes.
William Chittick provided its most influential English translation in his book, The Sufi Path of Knowledge.
The saying goes, I was a hidden treasure and I loved to be known, so I created creation in order to be known.
That saying holds a profound, beautiful paradox.
The entire created order, the earth, the rivers, the atmosphere, the heavens,
is a vast sign system addressed directly to a knower.
But the one being signed, the originator of all of it, remains completely hidden behind the signs.
Air is the loftiest similitude, the sign that announces the failure of signs.
It is the only sign at the absolute top of the cosmos whose very form insists that the signified is not on the same scale as the sign.
It points upward, and in the very act of pointing, it announces that it fails to capture what it points to.
So the disciple finally understands this.
He sees the massive ladder of signs they have built.
He sees the loftiest similitude standing at the very top encompassing everything else.
But human curiosity is relentless.
It is.
Having reached the top of the physical cosmos, he guides us one rung further.
He asks the ultimate terrifying question.
What stands between air and the creator?
Exactly.
What is that final threshold?
The scholar answers him, but with extreme caution.
He names the absolute limit of the dialogue allor.
The instance.
Yes, the instance, the doorway of divine will.
That originating moment is entirely unique.
Through it.
The originating command was commanded.
This is the exact boundary where the metaphor of error breaks down completely.
The master names this threshold, but he deliberately, carefully does not unfold it for the student.
Because this divine will is not something you can just map out like the islands or the rivers.
You cannot chart it on a piece of paper.
You really cannot.
We see the historical and theological weight of this in Paul Walker's study, Early Philosophical Shayism.
Oh yeah, he explains the Fatimid theological rigor on this
exact point.
The nature of this origination is beyond human categorization.
It is neither inside time the way ordinary moments are, nor is it outside time the way we usually imagine eternity.
It is the originating moment of time itself.
My brain is starting to knot up a bit just thinking about that.
It's meant to.
You can't map that.
You can't draw a line from before to after if the concept of before doesn't even exist yet.
That is exactly the trap the disciple is facing.
To explain the origination of time using our human categories of before and after would be to fold it back into the created order it is supposed to proceed.
You would be using time to describe the creation of time.
It is a logical impossibility that shatters the intellect's ability to comprehend it.
So the discipline of silence must be honored.
The scholar names the boundary but refuses to dissect it.
And the disciple, standing at this metaphysical boundary, feels the sheer vertigo of what he is looking at.
He has reached the end of his intellectual map.
And looking over the edge, he pleads with the teacher.
He asks to be returned to the lower physical world.
He fears for his soul and he genuinely fears for his intellect.
And honestly, looking at the sheer scale of this structure, I can see the argument here.
Yeah.
When you face the dizzying reality of approaching the
all the time, you realize that intellectual assent can very quickly turn into intellectual undoing.
The inner of the inner is not a place for the human intellect to casually wander.
The scholar recognizes the danger perfectly.
His reply matches the student's raw honesty.
He tells him directly that if he had unveiled those deeper meanings, if he had tried to force the disciple's mind past the origin of time, the disciple would have lost his vision entirely.
His mind would have broken.
To ground this terrifying reality, the master invokes Moses, peace be upon him.
And the figure traditionally called Khedir.
Yes, the scholar Moses met.
This is drawn from the chapter of the cave,
verses 60 through 82.
Moses seeks knowledge from this figure, assuming he can handle the weight of ultimate reality.
Specifically, the master's response mirrors the stark warning given in the chapter of the cave, verse 67.
Remind me what that one says?
Truly, you will not be able to bear with me patiently.
The scholar is using this exact dynamic as a self-aware closure for the disciple.
The teaching has finally reached its lofty edge.
To press even one step further would be to ask the disciple to bear what he is simply not yet equipped to bear.
The incredible architecture they have built together, from the earth to the heavens to the infinite expanse of air, must simply be allowed to settle quietly in the heart.
It's beautiful, really.
Air is the loftiest similitude, the sign that announces the failure of signs.
Which signs in your own life are being treated as peers of the one?
And what would change this week if the highest things you encounter were read as pointers that announced their own failure to capture him?